foreign
let's go out to Portland Oregon and talk
to Rich hey Rich what's up man
hey how you doing rocking and rolling
man what about you
I'm not doing okay
um what's up recent call today is uh I
my wife and I have been married for a
little over a year now uh we have a
three and a man uh three and a half
three and a half month old son
and uh recently she's uh well she's
bipolar too and she started going
through a hypomanic episode uh which
coming into the marriage I really had
very little idea of what sort of things
kind of surrounded bipolar too
um but as a result of it she uh decided
to kind of start her own business and
then spent
uh opened up some credit cards uh
without my knowledge and then uh spent
about seven to eight thousand dollars uh
and then was running around
missing most of the day uh while I was
home unfortunately I worked from home
but
I was home alone taking care of our
three and a half month old son
um but
I'm kind of at a point where uh it's she
she's gotten a little bit better it's
kind of de-escalated in the last couple
of weeks
um but some of the financial stuff is
still out there and so I'm just kind of
trying to figure out what what I should
be doing and how to be better prepared
for when this happens again the next
time
um oh man
there's a lot here um really quick for
the for the audience
um
bipolar 2 is
um a a relatively become relatively
common diagnostic diagnosis
um and it's different than bipolar one
from something they call hypomania which
means the UPS
the manic phase the phase where people
stay up for three or four days and that
goes on for weeks and then they collapse
and they're back up at it and they spin
recklessly or they will just go have a
ton of romantic part it looks different
for everybody but it's just a z
um
hypomanic means it's not quite as high
it's not quite Hispanic the other part
that usually accompanies bipolar too is
the depression phase
is often deeper it's a darker hole right
so
um
what you're describe
rich I have a lot of thoughts and
opinions some of which are going to get
me in trouble is it okay if I just
kind of lamb all out in a row
sure go ahead okay
I like to
this isn't always a hundred percent
accurate but it helps me okay so
feel free to not use this if it doesn't
help you
I don't like to say
anxiety caused this
or depression caused this or bipolar
made this because that infers that we
live completely robotic lives
and I know
several some of them very closely
bp1 and bipolar one and bipolar two
folks who have created worlds for
themselves
where they take their meds
where they
um they do a lot of work upstream and
when they do enter into a really dark
phase or a high phase they got a plan
so what I don't want you to do is to
just look at like oh gosh this is the
next seven years of my life this is just
going to happen at some random moment
you're going to get a call like hey your
wife bought seven cars and she started a
car business that's not necessarily
deterministic that way right so I would
love you to say well my wife has been
diagnosed at some point with bipolar too
and all right she recently did X Y or Z
okay see what I'm saying and so I don't
I want that's going to impact my hope is
that empowers you and gives you some all
right all right let's do this
that's different than oh this is gonna
be what this is okay so that's number
one number two um how long did y'all
date before you got married
uh for about two years and there was
never an episode never any sort of
anything like this you never experienced
any of it
uh no I had not the the closest we had I
was earlier this year her brother uh
also has bipolar and he went through a
similar episode
um so we at least had a little bit of it
but I even then I didn't really kind of
know what was going on I was basically
kind of third-party just hearing about
everything okay but I know she had
several years ago uh gone through
another episode I've heard from her
family what kind of uh precipitated from
that but
uh was it also a reckless spending and
borrowing episode as well
uh spending and actions yeah there was
like she got a tattoo as a result of it
and uh decided to kind of out of nowhere
just to get like a haircut which was you
know on on Surface nothing bad uh it's
very impulsive
yeah exactly all right so
um I'm gonna give you a recommendation
that I I fight against all of the time
and in 99.99 of the time I think is the
wrong move but I think it's the right
move for you right now
okay
what your wife needs what you need what
your household needs right now is you to
be able to find footing and to drop your
shoulders so that y'all can do what you
got to do coming forward
and you will not be able to do that I
don't believe until you know y'all are
safe
and so I think the smart thing to do
right now is to move your money into an
account where you can make sure the four
walls are covered your housing is taking
care of you utilities are taken care of
you can get gas money you get food
okay yeah fortunately I've already done
that good it doesn't look kind of early
on yet okay I think um couples who split
their finances I think that's a terrible
idea
except in this situation okay
um Step number two is she still burning
through cars or is she starting is the
light starting to come back on like oh
no because usually that's accompanied by
some pretty intense shame that then
kicks in the the black hole phase
uh no she has the stuff that can be
returned but wasn't like good since
there was services that we can't return
but the goods uh some of it has gotten
returned some of it we've found out we
really can't return
uh but we are kind of in the process of
getting all that and then
um we're hoping kind of by the end of
the month
be somewhat close to the the
other kind of shoe to drop on it was
that we have
before all this we had been saving for a
house and so we do have about forty
thousand dollars saved up in
savings for the house that we were gonna
basically just turn around and use that
to pay on the card so that they didn't
gather any sort of interest at all sure
but can you get I mean you she ran up
what eight or nine thousand so can she
just pay them off
um that was that basically that's going
to be the plan at this point is to just
pay them off with worth it I would not
do that
unless she agrees to freeze her credit
okay so that if there's another
impulsive moment that it's very
challenging to go forward
okay
and here's what we have to do moving
forward we have to create with her you
can't do this for her because you're not
her dad you're her husband she has to be
willing to create put hurdles in her
path
so that
um if she gets
um ends up acting very impulsively or
ends up and hurdles also
um for people who are
struggling with major depressive
disorder right or they are in a
depressive episode
maybe not how many guns in the house
maybe don't um there is a number
everywhere for somebody to call
we have a check-in program that we've
practiced right that there's there is
I'm gonna put some things in place so
that
I want to tell you I don't have bipolar
one or bipolar two nothing of the sword
and I also am pretty impulsive so
there's been seasons in my life when I
gave my debit card to my wife I didn't
have access to my own checking account
because I needed some time to cool off
and that was just me being a responsible
adult
okay there's most of the time I do not
have junk food candy in my house because
I eat all of it and I know that
um I should be disciplined and I know
that I should all those I know all that
it's often easier for me just to not
have it in the house
and I've made peace with that that's
okay
and so it's about her deciding I want to
be an adult and never put myself my
family in this position again
and
I've got some different challenges in
other people so I'm gonna put some
hurdles in front of me
would she be willing to do that or is
she not even a place to have that
conversation yet
probably not yet
um I mean right now she doesn't even see
the stuff as debt or her philosophy is
that it's not actually dead until uh
interest starts occurring on it
so we're
we're still kind of citing the whole
actually just using credit cards uh to
begin with but so it might be in
concerned she still she has started to
kind of calm down but
uh
kind of seeing just how still
active she is with the idea of wanting
to start her own business and whatnot uh
if you think she can if I mean I don't
know that you have the deterministic
like that but if y'all decide starting a
business is right for your young family
for her great let's just do it the right
way
yeah and we and we have tried to tell
her that between myself and parents
um and there's
been pushback but for the most part our
message has always been exactly that
it's just start off slow and scale yeah
absolutely
um but she wants to go and buy like she
wants to start a cafe is her idea so
um so I always recommend when somebody
wants to start a restaurant or a coffee
shop or open a bar go spend two years
working in a cafe
day in and day out
um sometimes where we love to go spend
time together it's a totally different
experience creating curating that
experience for somebody else to enjoy
their time because you're working right
but all it could say is
um that those conversations may fall in
deaf ears
um but I think they're at least worth
sitting on and having I think ultimately
you're gonna have to decide
um or she's gonna have to decide do I
want to be well or not well
and there is
um pharmaceutical interventions
especially in combination with
um therapeutic interventions right is
she seeing somebody
uh no not specifically right now with in
the midst of all this we did go to the
ER and they did adjust your meds
um so be we do have her on something
that's supposed to be helping her with
the hypomania specifically I think
you'll need to go spend some time with a
marriage counselor
okay and not just a run-of-the-mill one
but I would find a psychologist or
somebody who's trained working with
couples but also with
um uh uh mental health disorders
okay
and or somebody who's struggling with a
very particular thing and there are um
therapists that are excellent with
couples in bipolar excellent with
couples and borderline personality
disorder which is very challenging
um couples in OCD so there's there's
therapists that are really excellent at
at
helping couples draw boundaries helping
couples draw up plans so that we can
move forward What I Hear in your voice
and you just may be a super chill like
make your own granola Portland kind of
guy
but I hear in your voice you almost have
already given up
are you just tired
I think it's more the letter I'm just
exhausted okay uh trying to fight and
what not for what feels like a month now
I actually probably has been over a
month now it's just what are you
fighting
because let me tell you this in in a
manic phase there's no learning
so there's like having a re a
conversation about hey you know you
should probably go to bed
it's almost a a
conversation not worth having
or hey debt is actually this that's not
that's this isn't that moment for that
conversation
it's more hey honey
when we as a couple owe somebody money I
can't breathe
when we as a couple have to pay for a
restaurant that we haven't even opened
yet
we haven't done the math on how many
cups of coffee we actually have to sell
just to pay the light bill on that thing
much less the overhead much less the
cafe staff
I I
don't sleep I don't I don't breathe I
don't digest my food
um I think that's where we start
and that's different than starting with
math starting with hey this is actually
the definition of debt hey you shouldn't
scale this so much it is do you love me
enough to not hurt me because right now
your actions hurt they're scaring me to
death
and if you love me that if you love me
just that much just that much that's a
good place where we can start
right
that's the only way I've seen things be
effective I've rarely rarely ever seen
somebody win with a math problem or a
definition problem or something like
that but I think you guys got to get a
marriage counselor that's going to help
you as she comes down and um
I I think once the manic phase is over I
think getting meds readjusted again is
probably pretty important
um especially if she just got meds to
deal with the Mountaintop
um
yeah I'll leave it at that I think you
have to look at the entire picture of
your marriage I don't want you to cast
this thing off as this is going to be
the rest of your life or it has to be
the rest of your life it might be but it
doesn't have to be
um
she can make some choices
and you all can make some choices
together where this is not deterministic
um go ahead Kelly I have a question yes
so we had a call earlier
um in the week about bipolar one okay
and now bipolar two that's why I asked
you to explain it a little but I know
for most of us it's just
terms we don't get so I just want to I'm
wanting to know so it sounds like in one
the highs are higher and the lows are
lower is that is that it am I hearing
that correctly
yes I my understanding is the bipolar
one is is the intensity is is much
greater
and in bipolar two the highs aren't
quite as high
um but often is accompanied by a lower
low
um and so it that's
often the diagnostic is pretty
subjective right and
um with all due respect a lot of times
bipolar 2 is just something they throw
like I feel all over the place and I
feel really excited sometimes I feel
really low sometimes I can just put
bipolar 2 on there and call it and so it
is one of it's I think it's one of the
most overdiagnosed um Diagnostics and
I've met some folks where it's very real
right where it's very very real
um I
that's that's why he's got to be honest
about it if this is what you got it's
what you got
um similar like I struggle with X Y and
Z I still gotta be at work on time so I
have to create a world where I can be on
work on time so it's kind of the same
thing just different degrees of of the
symptoms to a point
for non-nerds yes okay and yeah yeah so
hyper means
a lot right and hypo means like the the
Mountaintop is curved it's more of a
hill than a mountain okay right it is
rarer than a hype hypomanic phase for
somebody to go on a spinning burnout
like this that's what makes me wonder if
there's more to it than that
um
or if this is just like a very
determined very very like we're going
forward
um or if there's a long family history
here that's why like it
when someone's listening saying why
don't you ask yes why don't you ask this
I think most of these questions for Rich
and his wife are gonna be for a
counselor because there's gonna be some
Nuance here that's that's gonna be when
he said that the um manic had been over
a month at this point how I mean I guess
I never thought that they lasted that
long because I've not never been around
anybody yeah that makes me very
that's that's that that in my estimation
is a long long long time okay because
that does seem exhausting it's a long
time
um for uh bipolar two hypomanic phase
um but again I'm not an expert on it
um there may be moments when they last
that long that seems like a very very
long time from my experience
um but again there's experts out there
if you are uh bipolar two bipolar one
expert I mean you've got some opinions
on that please write in and I'd love to
read out like hey here's if you're a
clinician and you're a psychologist
um and you are navigating this and your
your specialty is bipolar one and two I
mean I would love
um if you want to provide some clarity
um we'll read it if you write in I'll be
happy to read that out is for folks
listening
um but that's a great question but again
here's here's the bigger picture for
99.9 percent of us
those level of details
I think are only important if you use
them as limiting factors
and what I mean by that is
um
I'll just use this in my house
if I took I'm using my son who's in has
no mental health disorders whatsoever
he's an amazing young man I'm just using
him for an example if he was really
struggling and I took him to a child
psychologist who then did a work up on
him and said hey your child has bipolar
one
and then I took him to get a second
opinion and that person said his bipolar
too
I wouldn't care
what they have what I would want to know
is what is it about my son that he's
going to struggle with on a day-to-day
basis and what can we do so I don't care
if it's bipolar one and my UPS are like
this well this guy gave me bipolar too
but this has been a month now that
doesn't matter to me as much as
I felt so out of control for 30 days for
60 days I couldn't hear people who loved
me I spent recklessly I went bananas
let's start there the diagnostic fine
but let's start there and let's have
that conversation with the psychiatrist
let's have that conversation with a
psychologist and then again there's not
like one pill they can just like oh you
have an infection let's give you
penicillin that's not how that works
they're going to say okay let's try this
see if this works that didn't work let's
try this one let's try this one and it's
gonna be a slow management until that's
why they call it Med management until we
figure out
what for you works and that's why again
I just don't put a lot I don't care
about Diagnostics hardly ever
um it does if someone says I've been
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder that's that's a light bulb for
me somebody says I've been diagnosed
with bipolar one that's a light bulb for
me or schizophrenia most of the rest of
them is okay tell me what's going on in
your life
um and that's just again I don't want to
sound nonchalant but most people are way
more complex in their diagnosis in most
situations are way more complex so
um but that's what rich is dealing with
right that's what this rich is dealing
with with the wife he loves and I'm
confident she loves him
and also just kind of went rogue and
went out and bought a bunch of stuff
started a business got Mom and Dad
saying hey we love you and husband
saying hey we love you this isn't safe
this isn't smart this isn't safe I'm
just plowing head plan head plan ahead
we have to deal with that
um sometimes extra information is hey
here's the diagnosis okay cool that's
that's excellent we take that into
account but let's deal with hey we're
not safe because we've got a partner
who's just spinning recklessly that's
where I like people to start but does
that help
yeah that's great okay hopefully uh I
didn't put everybody to sleep just then
no I don't think so okay all right hey
Rich we love you man um call back
anytime if you need some if your wife
wants to call in and I can help her
create a road map
um we'll only have a few minutes but I'm
happy to give it a shot
um if she wants to call in as well